[Music]
good evening everyone
good evening you know - yes thank you
welcome to Copenhagen how do you feel oh
it's always nice to be back yeah thank
you so much for having me when we were
first here December 2007 and then the
summer of 2011 yeah you know as well I
don't know about anything about that but
been here twice yeah
June ideas we're sitting here and we're
in a building that's about six million
books laying around somewhere out there
it's a big library and I know that
you're a total bookworm how do you feel
about libraries like this I was a very
comforting you know but I I think these
days libraries immediately provoke the
question about how the funding you know
because in the States we have this
wonderful tradition of free public
libraries but they're desperately
underfunded but you know I'm one of
those kids who when I think of the
central institutions that helped shape
me the library certainly primary among
them good places if you're gonna grow up
in any of these kind of crazy places
it's probably best to grow up inside of
a library I sort of did you know yeah
and look where it got you yeah I don't
know if my family's pleased but it got
me somewhere what would you and your
feel about sitting here in the library
well I mean the one thing about writing
characters is that it's really easy to
write people who are smarter than you
you just look [ __ ] up you know so he's a
person who's as a character as a kind of
a sort of a you know an arrow to logical
figure he's a lot smarter than me so
I'm sure if I thought about it he would
be delighted but you know I'm not sure
he's as delighted as I am he'd be a
little more skeptical wouldn't he I
think I'm more skeptical of him but yeah
yeah not because I necessarily have
skepticism as a kind of an operational
code it's just that being a visitor
always gives you a skewed relationship
to any place when you just cruise
through something you barely see
anything and I remember how many times
it was when I would work inside of an
institution and folks would come and
visit and they would be like oh this
[ __ ] is great and you're at the job
thinking well [ __ ] burn this place
down
first chance I get so you know the
disparities between being inside and
just sort of being a guest is always
stark I guess I just wanted to mention
junior because he's such a steady sort
of figure in your writing and as Lisa
just said you have agreed to come here
and talk to us in the context of a whole
series of talks and activities that have
the topics of migration colonialism
racism all these themes that have been
acutely present for some people for many
years but that seem to have become also
acutely present for some of us who have
been in the privileged position of not
having to think too much about those
themes until recently it seems like
something is going on where it's
becoming more central even to people who
could brush off these themes earlier on
anyway what I wanted to say with this
was that these are very conflict at
topics they're full of anger division
controversy around them but to me
literature and I think your works are
great examples of this can oftentimes
make us understand questions about
migration colonialism racism in ways
that are more fruitful than discussions
are sometimes so this leads to a
question and it is when you became an
author when Union asked awha and Lola
were born were you conscious that you
wanted to tell stories that were would
also address these themes yeah I mean
most certainly I I was a I was someone
who was obsessed with the Caribbean as a
spaciality of forgetting to be someone
who's born and raised in the Caribbean
means that you grow up in the heart of
perhaps the greatest amnesia that the
world has ever inflicted upon itself and
in amnesia that's lived not only at an
international level but to lived locally
the average person I grew up with wasn't
exactly interested in reviewing or
rehearsing sort of the most traumatic
parts of our history but that wasn't on
the table that wasn't that wasn't part
of the you know the lunch box I I was
very very interested in this I think I
was one of these kids who through
certain turns in my life I was given to
certain kinds of exposures that made me
vulnerable to these histories I had a
grandfather who
seemed to have a an invested interest in
making sure that before his
grandchildren left the island for the
United States that they had certain
things in their mind in certain
recollections and so my grandfather
wanted to make sure that we understood
that we were children of African descent
that we've been the descendants that we
were the descendants of slaves that
slavery was an infinite cruelty from
which the world had yet to begun to
reckon and this of course is my
interpretation now as an adult when I
think about some of the crazy [ __ ] my
grandfather was doing in some ways he
was a lot smarter than anyone that I
knew growing up was because he sort of
came at these things symbolically you
know I think he understood something
about children that I still come to
terms with which is you know he
understood that we would remember
symbols in ways that we would not
remember perhaps even language and I
still remember my grandfather we were at
a sugarcane field
my grandfather worked a sugarcane field
almost his entire life you were at
coffee he worked all of the kind of the
consumer drugs of the new world that
sort of underwrote the new worlds early
wealth and I still remember there so
clearly I couldn't have been but five
years old and he showed us the you know
chains that that they would put on the
enslaved Africans and I still remember
him showing this to us and him saying
yes this is what they used to put you in
and as a kid I was kind of like what the
[ __ ] is he talking about man
you know you don't have a free man but
also you're like I don't know what the
hell I don't got the context for this
but
it was a mysterious moment that began to
make sense to me the older I got and the
more that I studied so therefore you
know start there and I become a history
major my public university this was back
in the day when public universities in
the United States were still affordable
you know and you could in the United
States is quite different from perhaps
someplace like Denmark but in the United
States at that time you could actually
as someone like me could actually work a
regular job and pay my University and
not go entirely insane and so I was at
this university and I my area of studies
was enslavement in the Caribbean and
maroon communities in the black Atlantic
and this was before I began to write any
kind of literature so long way of saying
that in some ways a lot of my interests
that ended up being reflected in a you
know hopefully a subtle way and the
literature came out of a premeditated
study of these these histories and it
almost sounds like it's recovering of
yourself in a way because you say that
you're born into a speciality of
forgetting so it almost sounds like this
is a lost memory that you're working on
recuperating yeah I I don't know if I
would have ever engaged in it if it
wasn't for the fact that you know the
United States and by extension Europe
are so gleefully committed to not
remembering [ __ ] you know it's like
fantastic I mean this the amount of
energy that Europe and North America and
by extension the other settler colonies
like Israel and Australia and New
Zealand expend unseeing reality Jesus
Christ you could move Jupiter into
another galaxy
it's like tremendous amount of energy
and I think when you encounter
that that sort of systematic and robust
politics of amnesia for me was very
striking and in some ways it also made
me curious why we're a [ __ ] American
soul goddamn obsessed with Columbus but
so disinterested in the sights which he
quote-unquote discovered slash colonize
destroyed and one sense there was this
what we would call forgetting to
remember you know or remembering to
forget Columbus stands there as a device
that helps them forget even more and
that was really curious and for me of
great interest because it helps in some
ways as an artist it's really useful as
an artist to know what the culture
wishes to abolish alright because it's
an artist you're not interested in the
artist who is interested in reminding
the culture what it [ __ ] knows is in
for a long week you know you're you're
going to do any productive work as an
artist you're gonna go the places where
everyone is strenuously trying not to
look and certainly for those of us of
African descent for those of us from the
Caribbean we are the grammar in which
the new world forgets if the whole new
world by we mean this world since
enslavement if it has an operating
system it is written in the zeros and
ones of it's slaved Africans we forget
everything based on the technologies of
forgetting that we first implemented
with forgetting the great crimes in the
new world and this was an artist it was
both useful personally but also I think
important for my own aesthetics you know
because you can do really I would argue
interesting work
if you're interested in your cultures in
a sort of curious way we're gonna move
on to American mainland in just a second
but I just want you to talk a little bit
more about the Caribbean and forgetting
in the Caribbean what is it what is that
society in which this very active
forgetting is going on all the time
except perhaps with your granddad what
does that do to country or a society in
which kids grow up well I mean I don't
want to kind of paint my grandfather
some special person just because I'm
related to him I think that there's a
whole ton of people who you know are
very invested in trying to recall and
trying to keep alive and trying to mark
and try to kind of archive and many many
different levels it's been in some ways
one of the most important branches of
Caribbean epistemology when we think if
we think of modernity as organized
around the terms of forgetting and the
terms of what is described as
coloniality that there's been a kind of
a counter modernity which includes some
of these things that are happening in
the Caribbean but I tell you I look
we're in Denmark you know [ __ ] if
anybody remembers there was a Danish
Caribbean you know even in the Caribbean
a lot of people don't remember there's a
[ __ ] Danish Caribbean I used to date
this woman from st. Thomas her
grandfather was named Ulrich I was like
oh [ __ ] there was a Danish Caribbean you
know and if you can have those
encounters perhaps it sparks it but you
know it matters quite a bit that we have
these extraordinary complex histories
that make so many of us complicit in so
much fucked-up [ __ ]
man I think it's significant because
after all what is contemporary status
policies or status politics if not in
other words you guys you're all in the
middle of an election right yes local
election I mean that local state larger
federal ultimately view politicians are
making vast arguments for complexity you
all have a wider arrangement of
political parties therefore perhaps you
have some candidates that are making
arguments for complexity complexity is
what you need to be able to hold these
things you know for there to be a
recollection of Danish colonialism and
imperialism in the Danish present would
require a complexity that most of I
would argue the mainstream politicians
are not interested in the constitute
format I understand very little the
constitution of Danish subjectivity does
not involve colonialism does not involve
enslavement Danes seem to have this
really wonderful fiction at least
mainstream Danish pull out politics
seems to have this wonderful fiction
that Denmark is this kind of unified
cohesive you know space and the rest of
the world is on some [ __ ] and we're
all Danes and [ __ ] what are we gonna do
with these outsiders well that's that's
only possible if that's only possible if
we pretend the Danes have never left
Denmark
I don't know I just I mean but I don't
know I just I always the joke is you
could be at the bottom of a [ __ ] mine
in Peru and you will encounter a Danish
person it's an in just at the level of
at the level of at the level of what we
would call neoliberal capital there is a
hundred and thirty corporations Danish
corporations in Vietnam the [ __ ] are a
hundred and thirty Danish corporations
doing in Vietnam well we know what the
[ __ ] they're doing in Vietnam they are
predating the way neoliberal
corporations do they're behaving in
their usual predatory models and so this
fiction that all of us as nations have
whether it's the United States or
whether it's Denmark that we're just our
kind of space and that these other maps
that show us who we really are
those maps are irrelevant that they're
fake news that we shouldn't constitute
ourselves but I don't know a map of
Denmark doesn't look like Denmark a map
of Denmark needs to include the stupid
wars y'all get into it needs to include
why the [ __ ] is your what a [ __ ] is your
incredibly violent capitalism all over
the world what the hell are so many
Danish people doing freely travelling
all over the planet while they're at
home arguing that nobody should travel a
nares place or at have it their place
but this is theirs
but the same thing is true for the
United States is that we draw maps of
our national identity that are not
accurate
they are alibis and they are there to be
alibis so that we can be innocent of the
crimes we committed or innocent of what
we have done even if it doesn't rise to
the occasion of crime and the United
States is very true most Americans are
like america [ __ ] yeah well I'm like
well we got over a hundred and twenty
something bases in over a hundred and
twenty something countries where does
America and therefore as artists it's
for me more interesting as an artist to
be engaged at that level of complexity
the predator the violator the rapist has
the privilege of not remembering that's
the advantage of being a predator a
predator never remembers all these
actors who attack a assault vilely all
of these people they're like oh I don't
remember that of course you don't
because what predator needs to remember
and I think that again most of us as
artists I assume the tradition of being
an artist is not because you're
interested in you know the technologies
of predation forgetting impunity yeah
those things I think are done very well
by our elders and by our corporate and
political leaders we're trying to fill
different roles and this has been a lot
of what has gotten me thinking because I
come from a country that the United
States invaded and occupied on a number
of occasions and yet no American
remembers yet no Dominican forgets
and so where is the map of America do
the Predators draw the map or do those
who they predate to all the map and
certainly literature affords us new
cartography the way music does the way
dance does the way all the arts mean
[ __ ] if artists weren't drawing maps we
would be completely lost and I know as a
kid I would have been entirely lost in
all of these investigations if it hadn't
only been for artists and scholars I
mean shoot
I sometimes wonder let's talk about your
literature then because you talk about
complexity but what I think is really
amazing about good literature and your
literature is that it takes what's
complex and it turns it into stories and
stories can be complex but they're not
frightening they are human and
recognizable and I want to ask you to
just read a little bit from a story that
and I thought of four to two years ago
when I made a dear friend lillas who was
a Syrian refugee who came to Europe like
many others at that time and when she
told me what it had been like to move
into a Danish provincial town Estes
she's a single mom with her two boys and
kind of like that's that's what it was
like it's just like why are they all
inside why don't they come out I thought
of as scene from one of your stories in
Viana and it's a story about arriving
into the new country and I want to ask
you to just read a little bit from it I
think it's page 123 thank you that was a
wild ass laugh yeah I liked it
it's literally I am and I'm not taking
the piss but that's literally what I
sound like
right before I teach yeah I always uh I
know we have some young people in the
audience I I always tell young people
that I'm encouraging to be a professor
or to be on faculty I'm like you could
never be worse than me so knock yourself
the [ __ ] out on that note I'll read you
these two little paragraphs yeah from
the top of Westminster our main strip
you could see the thinnest sliver of
ocean cresting the horizon to the east
my father had been shown that site the
management showed everyone but if he
drove us in from JFK he did not stop to
pointed out the ocean might have made us
feel better considering what else there
was to see London Terrace itself was a
mess half the building still needed
there wirings and in the evening light
these structures sprawled about like
ships of brick that had run aground mud
followed gravel everywhere in the glass
the grass pant planted late in the fall
poked out of the snow in dead Tufts each
building has its own laundry my father
explained my mother looked vaguely out
the snout of her parka and nodded
that's wonderful she said I was watching
the snow sift over itself
terrified and my brother was cracking
his knuckles this was our first day in
the States the world was frozen solid
yeah old Jersey
Jerzy thank you
[Music]
can you talk a little bit about this
state that the boys in this story is
just about to enter right now which is
the state of the immigrant of the person
who kind of carries around two worlds at
the same time while being in a place
that only carries around one at least it
feels like that can you talk about what
it is about that way of being in the
world that appeals to you in your
writing oh yeah
again I my own experience of immigrating
to the United States was a little
shocking I have nephews and cousins now
who you know the youtubes they they're
on that ship so much they know more
about the United States sometimes than I
do
I am agreat at the United States in 1974
it's like you know I had no images zero
images the United States I grew up I
only had a TV in our neighborhood for
like a few months before we immigrated
and it seemed like the only thing they
[ __ ] played was a these 1968 Ralph
batchi spider-man cartoons so I didn't
have much of a glimpse of it so America
was a bit of a surprise and New Jersey
more so and I was very curious as an
artist too could I possibly capture some
of this yeah I think that you know
especially when one is a child since one
doesn't have any precedent one assumes
that this is what happens
yeah like when you're six years old you
assume that this always happens that
you're one day you're living in Santo
Domingo and the next day you're living
in parlin new jersey you're just like
that's what's going to happen you
naturalize what itself is an incredible
disruption and and it was fascinating
and
later I began to understand what the
[ __ ] had happened but at that time it
was like time travel plus being in a
rocketship at one time you know plus the
70s and trying to come to terms with
some of these things you know I think
was real interesting for me I despite
what people think English is a [ __ ]
shitty language to try to learn lots of
Danes seem to speak [ __ ] English but
I found English to be incredibly
difficult really really difficult not
least of all because of the size of its
syllabary like its vocabularies immense
and yeah and that was a shocker and then
I also found out that you know America
has a really strange [ __ ] that people do
you've got to learn so much as a kid
when you're an immigrant I often think
that our societies spend so much time
talking about immigrants so that we
don't ever [ __ ] have to listen to
their stories you know I mean America
y'all know the United States like
Denmark it's talk so much about
immigrants but in some ways it's to take
up the whole conversation it's like it's
both the United States and I assume
Denmark it's like we're still in this
middle of this trial should we put all
immigrants in concentration camps or
should we not you know jury's still
[ __ ] out but part of that is you know
it's because it would be very difficult
to actually listen to immigrants why is
it difficult to listen to immigrants the
same reason our societies even in a
society as enlightened as Denmark
doesn't want to listen to women
what's the reason because people who
don't have the historical power have
information to bring about a society the
society doesn't really want to hear I
mean even in Denmark which has its you
know vaunted egalitarianism if every
[ __ ] dude shut up for a year
you would learn [ __ ] about yourself
you'd never learned I promise you I
promise you
y'all like Bernie Sanders utopia but
you'd learn some [ __ ] and I think it's
the same thing if every single person
who wasn't an immigrant which shut da
[ __ ] up about immigration for a year and
listened to immigrants
I think the society would learn stuff
about itself then most societies don't
want to hear most societies don't want
to hear we don't want to hear that we
are not friendly and we don't want to
hear that we are not good and we don't
want to hear that in fact we are not
hospitable and it's very difficult you
know what we want to hear is gratitude
all I want from you is [ __ ] gratitude
and why we demand gratitude from
immigrants is so that we therefore would
never have to practice it we extract so
much [ __ ] from poor people from women
from folks who have disabilities from
everybody who's on the receiving end of
our crap we want them to be grateful so
that we can hide how much we have earned
from them and so well you know again as
a kid I spent my entire childhood being
told be grateful and when you would
every word out of your mouth is you've
being grateful how can you tell the
[ __ ] truth as children we hear this
right our parents will put their foot in
our ass and they're like be grateful and
many of us are 50 years old and we're
still figuring out how do we tell the
truth about our parents how do we tell
the truth about our childhoods I mean
[ __ ] you're lucky if you're not if
you're in a relationship and your
partner isn't still wrestling with what
it meant to be in their family
gratitude chokes the truth that of
people and this was also an important
thing for me to work myself out as an
immigrant because you know most
immigrants have children and most
children are caught in the double bind
of being children and immigrant and
societies that doesn't want to hear from
either you're the most disqualified from
bearing knowledge you're the most
disqualified from bearing truth a child
word is rarely held up in a court of law
of anything yet as an artist I think
that most of us really are interested in
these disavowed voices and I want to ask
you about this being caught up between
two cultures because it's also often how
migrant literature is described how your
literature is described and of course
that is part of what it is but I also
get the sense with your characters that
they are also wiser that they also have
an extra layer with which to look at the
same world as everyone else because
they're from somewhere else or because
they have this other reference you know
it's a layer of reflection that I also
just think gives something that's almost
the opposite energy from the gap from
the constriction of being caught it's
also a way to tell stories that's the
way it feels when when I read your books
can you recognize that well I mean yeah
I mean I I think a pest
I think epistemic privilege is real you
know I think that what we call epistemic
privilege this idea that when we I was
saying earlier that women have
information about this society that the
society because these two here because
this is epistemic privilege those of us
who are at disadvantages understand the
society better than people who are
advantage if I was in look if I was an
alien and I needed to understand this
society I wouldn't be [ __ ] speaking
to anyone with money or power you just
round up
ten or twelve people were having shitty
lives and they can draw a better map for
you than anyone who's got regular meals
and certainly this is for real yeah but
part of the distortion and part of what
really interests me as a writer is that
these moments of clarity that we often
get because we are marginalized right we
have these what we call productive
marginalization z' is almost always
undermined because being marginalized is
[ __ ] hard work you know you can have
insights but when you're working these
60 hour a week jobs like I was working
when I was a kid that insight doesn't go
very far you're too [ __ ] tired and so
you oscillate with sometimes catching a
glimpse of the society and but other
times never being able to see anything I
mean I still remember my [ __ ] older
sister saying to me you know as she was
raising her two children by herself
she's like every now and then I remember
that I am smart and the exhaustion of
the structures of our lives sometimes
undermine these things and for me when I
think of these characters I think of
them in that way is that sometimes they
have some insights that are piercingly
important but almost always they're
undone by their own emotional
distortions by the kind of pressure
these societies put on people and again
that's what makes for me it makes the
literature very rich it makes the
characters sort of textural lives rich
you know it certainly defines what I
felt my childhood was you know and I was
in college I'd you know college was
weird because we work so goddamn [ __ ]
hard and we hit so little money every
now and then we were so [ __ ]
brilliant
and then we would be like [ __ ] I'm out
of rent money you know and that takes up
all your energy you know or [ __ ] what am
I gonna do next and I find that that
moment that space to be at least the
place that I'm drawn to as her as an
artist it's a defining space or a space
in which you to
and become yourself no no it's that it's
the it's the site of a great struggle
you know few are the people who find
spaces where they have an enormous realm
of deliberation where they have endless
time to be to think to create most of us
are earning this stuff by cutting other
parts of ourselves off I want to talk
about you about America but can we just
talk a little bit about six yeah for
someone who's seen is AB sort of
political and activist writer and for
someone who's a public intellectual and
so on your books are full of sex what is
what's up with that well I actually
think they're much more full of intimacy
you know I'm not so sure there's a lot
of sex acts described the actual yeah
yeah I mean it's not that I just um the
longings and and the ways that certain
character logical sexual ization z-- can
enter into narratives you know there's
certain ways that people think about the
world it can be highly sexualized and um
certainly that's something that if you
grew up hegemonic email if you grew up
with the kind of the standard
masculinity of whatever society it is
it's often that usually comes for free
as part of the kit I would me it was
just intimacy is such a fantastic space
where most of us reveal ourselves or are
terrified to reveal ourselves it is in
people's intimate lives in the ways that
we long in the ways that we connect or
don't connect in the way see we succeed
in the way we fail that so much is
revealed you know think about race think
about how race works
you could study race all day long but if
you leave out how racialized the sexual
economy of our world is you lose out an
enormous sense of the way race works
yeah
in intimacy so much crap gets played out
so much crazy [ __ ] like it's almost as
if all the force fields of the lies that
we tell ourselves begin to become undone
and because of course deep down we're
constantly fed all these stories about
intimacy that don't really work all that
well in the real world you know and and
and those of us who begin to engage in
intimacy when we're at high school were
at college we begin to realize that for
intimacy to work we have to [ __ ] stop
lying and most of us are so busy lying
to ourselves we couldn't imagine any
other way who the [ __ ] wants to reveal
to themselves that they're not as smart
as they think they are but they're not
as cute as they think they are that
they're not as kind as they think they
are you know that in fact what they
learned from Love was almost nothing
from their parents or from their society
that mostly what they have are dreams
secondhand given to them by storytellers
and it's tough it's tough most of us get
in bed with each other with masks on and
how long it takes to take masks off now
of course there's differences yeah this
society encourages women to take their
masks off as soon as possible for very
complicated reasons yeah but those of us
who've been to this you know to this
pony show know that like the closest you
can come
to any form of telepathy the closest you
come to getting outside of your
subjectivity is in deep intimacy and
that is a strange place for us because
my god to reveal yourself to someone
else who can then take that revelation
and destroy you with it no it's it's
it's a terrible challenge you know it's
a terrible challenge and there should be
awards given because so many of us do it
despite the risks and for me it's not so
much when my friends at my age are like
all love it's so hard the [ __ ] doesn't
work it's so hard to find somebody I'm
always like it's amazing it works at all
given how flawed we are as humans we're
all flawed it's there's nothing wrong
with us it's just it's hard we're in a
hard world and we have very vulnerable
hearts and for me it's always been a
great utopian site because given how
little we learn about love given what
this world teaches us and it's so cruel
what it teaches us given how often we
are failed by our parents and by the
adults in our lives too sometimes no
fault of their own that so many of us
still find the energy to get in there
and to give it a [ __ ] try speaks well
of us and as an artist I was taught that
boys shouldn't be interested in stories
about intimacy and as an artist you
can't help it you know if as soon as
they tell you you shouldn't be
interested in that you need to run for
it
mm-hmm I come from a military family you
could read all three of my books and
never have a sense of what a military
family I come from yeah I come from a
family where all of that [ __ ] was just
completely rejected my family was
shooting firearms
every weekend it was boxing every
weekend everything but vulnerability
yeah we were the the Dominican version
of the fry core you know impenetrable
homo social and weird you know so for me
I think it was my rebellion and a family
like mine where love was for you know
gender traitors in some way it was a
place for me to go so I didn't have to
be with my father who just would get an
erection every time he loaded his gun
that's a weird space yo yeah that's what
I'm wondering buzz this intimate space
exists which isn't about power relations
about politics about the masks is it
like a utopia or is it there you just
have to struggle enough together utopia
is it a utopia is it some state of Trent
for me apologies to all the other
interpretations utopia isn't a state of
transcendence
we don't put down all our human
limitations for me intimacy isn't about
that we stop being deeply flawed scared
people it is that in spite of all these
flaws we try to manage them I don't want
to be in love with some perfect dream
person I want to be in love with
somebody just like me it's [ __ ] up
it's scared but who is at least making
an effort to manage them and I think the
dream of transcendence has been one of
the most troubling radiations to come
out of the project of the Enlightenment
and it continues to haunt us you know
certainly haunts us in love but there's
also something about images of something
that looks like in the besi that is very
that shakes you and I'm saying this
because we went down and saw the
exhibition that Lisa was talking about
just now about
blind angles of Danish colonial history
and the image that I've remembered ever
since it opened is the image that's also
on the posters for it and it's of
Carribean nanny sitting with a small
white Danish girl and it's a photo that
looks intimate in a parental way almost
but it isn't necessarily we don't know
of course we don't know what the reality
behind the photo ills but when we were
looking at it you are also talking about
questions about intimacy that are raised
by a picture like that what were you
what did you think when you saw it well
I mean I think one of the primary one of
the look one of the for me one of the
primary extracts of exploitation is
effective labor in other words emotional
labor the fact that how many if we just
take it from that sort of a simplistic
gender binary how many women do an
enormous amount of effective labor
they're like hey I'm a dude I'm like
watch you carry my [ __ ] nervous
system for me and if if I again even in
Bernie Sanders Danish utopia I have a
have a bunch of Danish friends and let
me tell you you're a lot of the women
are doing a lot of effective labor here
yeah and so and take it to of racial
modality the we were talking earlier
about immigration look what we're
talking about immigration at a place
like Denmark or the United States we're
talking about race it's a polite term
the immigration is profoundly racialized
part of the reason we're demanding
gratitude from immigrants is because we
want them to do effective labor we're
like we're gonna hate you but you're
gonna learn to love us
there's a fair fight and when you hate
us we're gonna blame you for hating us
all right that sounds fair and the same
way that we see in the enslavement
period the gender division the amount of
effective labor that enslaved women had
to do in these economies was enormous
and it continues to play itself out I
mean you can see the echoes of this at
every stage I mean for those of us
who've been to New York it seems like
half a [ __ ] denmark's been in New
York but I just the amount of Colored
nannies who do this effective labor in
these wealthy and even sometimes just
affluent communities and I think that in
a situation where your community doesn't
have parity of power there can be no
real effective relationships these are
just bizarre distortions you know that
you need certain kinds of parity and
when you get these yawning abysmal
inequalities like you see in slavery we
can't even begin to talk about that as
human relationships these things are
almost demonic what's being demanded of
enslaved people to perform these kinds
of work and let me tell you it is hard
to convince people that effective labor
is an exploitation that our emotional
energies are finite and when we take
certain groups and ask them to do
emotional work
for a society that is unfair and unequal
we're taking parts of people's souls but
we don't have any calibers to measure
this and yet this I think will be
something that and we imagine in the
future when folks become I would argue
more sophisticated that this will be one
of the great crimes that our societies
will be remembered for that we commit
effective crimes on people that we ask
people to love those that hate them that
we ask people to graft they're
invincible and infinite affections onto
criminals that's it's a remarkable thing
that we do and we'll pay for that I
promise you where this this can't go
without a reckoning yeah so just explain
to me this parity of power because I'm
thinking will there ever be this parity
of power like if I want to go to work
and have someone help me raise my kids
by being paid to look after them am i
then in no matter what the circumstances
surrounding that am I then robbing them
of their effective resources or are
there ways in which we can help each
other with bringing up our kids and in
groups well of course we are I mean of
course we are but look the situation
isn't that we're not all inside of a
contradiction we live in a society that
we are all inside of contradictions
nobody's got their hands clean show me a
single person anywhere in the world who
is it complicit in some sort of madness
for me the issue is less that this is a
simple thing of a Maya criminal or not
the issue is that we can begin to think
about this in sophisticated ways
therefore permit ourselves to begin to
imagine and create remedies that would
be more useful to
for me guilt is is useless because
there's there's better ways for us to
act are we robbing people's effective
labor well sure we're robbing people's
Labor's all the time these are the
contradictions of our society even when
we pay them well depends on what we're
paying them the the issues are always
around is their fair recompense and in
societies where effective laborers are
not organized they're scarcely going to
be any recompense you know if ected
laborers don't have a union and if it's
not recognized as a central labor it's
gonna be a tough issue but I'm saying
this from personal experience I come
from a very poor Dominican family and
yet there's always somebody more poorer
than us and my mother was always able to
find somebody who was far poorer than we
were to help her and I lived in this
economy and it made me give me things to
think about our complicity should be
there to energize us towards
strategizing better ways of being
complicity is not there to shut us all
down it's we're all in this [ __ ]
some of us eat better than the others
sure
some of us benefit more than the others
but these systems are here to imprison
us all some people think that because
they're wardens they're free they're not
and it's gonna take a lot for us to get
around this stuff yeah but again it's
it's one of those things where there's
nothing very heroic about thinking about
these things you know I think a lot of
times we're we're we're told not to
think too much about them but I'm always
curious that makes you curious I'm
always curious I watched my mom hire
somebody to raise us and then I watched
my mom when I was a teenager be hired to
raise
other people's children and it makes you
curious so give us your advice I mean I
know that as Lisa mentioned you you said
in policing the other day that you found
it a little odd that immigration would
be the biggest problem we have in
Denmark and I can see how coming from
any other country that looks perhaps
unlikely just quantitatively speaking
what is your advice if people here want
to participate in being better at you
know being better at being engaged in a
multicultural society in which we handle
all these complexities what's the best
advice for that again I I'm an artist
I'm no expert but then again we all seem
to put non experts in charge of [ __ ] so
you know look I did I'm always stuck in
the same situation I we have a ton of
[ __ ] young people who we can say all
we want about young people but there is
not a 17 year old in this room who
couldn't [ __ ] run America better to
donna tronca [ __ ] break and so that's
not and that's not to dam the 17 year
old which show what you know which small
praise these we're in a situation where
our societies our politics are being
organized to console the elderly the
politics of the United States and
Denmark are consolations for old people
mm-hmm who fear a shrinking world who
fear an invader who fear a B C D where
for the most part our elites are old
predators who are stealing the horizons
of young people that's the truth of it
and so the issue for me is less like
these issue by issue things where it's
like immigration how do we stop being so
white supremacists all these matter
me intimately but it's certainly not
going to come from
having a society that seems to have no
interest in their young people except as
a way to create debt from them you know
I and I was thinking about Denmark I
teach at a university system I teach at
MIT and we have a lot of Danish refugees
from the university system I mean this
is a university system that is under
neoliberal assault this is a university
system where it's faculty don't feel
secure where you produce graduate
students who you can't give any [ __ ]
jobs to this society has no problems
underwriting with corporate welfare its
mineral corporations but seems to not be
able to find jobs for its most brilliant
grad students in academia there's a lot
that's going on but I think that as most
of us know when we belonged to
neoliberal societies we're being told
that the fire is over here I mean didn't
they just throw out was it the law
faculty used to be in the center of this
city but they move the law library or
something out of the city okay well
there you go is your first step but
these are neoliberal decision to do the
universities here on their own property
I don't know they don't if I recall they
pay rent to the government and so when
the government finds a boutique that can
pay higher rent there's a lot of weird
[ __ ] around here you know a lot of weird
[ __ ] it's a tough place to be a young
person despite what Bernie wants to say
talk about what's changed for you after
this election
and I mean you're a public intellectual
you're a professor you're a writer but
you're also an American man in the
middle of a country that's undergoing
some wild transformations what does that
meant for the way you're living your
life at the moment
well you know nobody wants to live when
[ __ ] Trump is around who the hell
wants that you know but you know to
quote Lord of the Rings we can't choose
the time that we're born in we can't
choose the struggle that's handed to us
you know fortunately for me I've always
been sort of a member of the kind of the
pugnacious let's get organized
solidarity we're a struggle I'm all into
that [ __ ] so I didn't like it it's not
fun to have America's white supremists
chapters all energized and activated and
for those of us who wanted to live the
dream that America was America - the KKK
it's been harder to live that dream the
centrality of white supremacy in so many
of our societies is something that can't
be argued with it yet most people want
to argue about it Donald Trump makes
that argument harder fortunately a lot
of people have responded with an
enormous amount of fight I mean what
else can we you know what else can we
hope for there are other planes of
existence there's other dimensions where
there's a Donald Trump in office and
people are like not wanting to fight
Jenna and I was thinking about that
because I went to grad school when the
Iraq war started in the States and I
remember this really lazy way walk out
from classes and the professors were
like think come on guys and we were like
nah we like our English class and
there's almost as taboo against speaking
about politics among lots of the
students and it just seems like now
campuses not least our battlegrounds
some some but you know for those of us
who are kind of interested in histories
you never know which generation is gonna
tear [ __ ] up
people were saying before black lives
matter exploded that this was the most
complacent lame generation these young
people don't want to organize and in
black lives matter explodes and I'm like
well what happened all that [ __ ]
rhetoric yep I think it's human beings
are not the hunger games we never know
when we're going to be heroic
we never know it's it's so unpredictable
and I think that that's the same
surprises that brought this [ __ ]
idiot into power are the same surprises
that bring certain kinds of struggle and
solidarity into existence and I often
think again the emphasis that we often
have on blaming the young people for
their not so energized why aren't they
burning this [ __ ] down I'm like I don't
know given the amount of pressure and
the amount of just disgusting distortion
that our society
pumps into young people I think they're
[ __ ] kicking ass I think that there's
plenty of us who wouldn't have held it
together if we had to grow up in these
neoliberal derangements you know we can
do just much to criticize all
generations but you know we're doing as
best we can we have trillions of dollars
aimed at us to shut us the [ __ ] up to
put us the [ __ ] to sleep to have us only
shop given how much money they throw at
us they're not as satisfied as you would
think they aren't they're like [ __ ] it
ain't working crank up YouTube Instagram
anything you know it's it's difficult
their challenges I'm not under selling
the challenges but you're saying that
something is in the air this things
happening around
I a couple hundred years ago I was owned
by people a couple hundred years ago no
one in my community of African descent
was permitted to have intimacy with whom
they wanted to it all depends what your
context is what's possible hmm
I belong to a community that overthrew
the greatest empires in the world with
very little perhaps it's just foolish of
me to think that we're still in the
place where we can do the same thing but
that's perhaps because I I believe
strongly in the lessons of the ancestors
that live inside of all of us this they
are not unbeatable and they've never
been we show this again and again again
and again they rise up and again and
again we fight there is no end there is
no transcendence we are not going to
cure human beings the fight will go on
and we have to just accept that that's
part of our cycle some years we get
[ __ ] neoliberal war mongering
immigrant hating Obama some years we get
war mongering neoliberal immigrant
hating Donald Trump we just keep
fighting you know some years we get very
lucky too so I'm all about that [ __ ]
so I can see how does something really
encouraging about some kinds of
consensus not working anymore because at
least Donald Trump has made that I don't
know he's made things very clear in a
way where it's been easier to see that
not everyone is going to like buy into
this system but I also have a feeling
and this may be white privilege speaking
that people are not there's not a lot of
common ground a lot of conversations go
wrong at the moment a lot of a lot of
people say we don't have anything in
common this is a sense in the air of
disillusion or I don't know what it is
but and it could be just my white angst
or it could be some reaction against you
no lies falling down about our shared
wonderful Western civilization project
but do you recognize the feeling that
again I think it's convenient that I
mean yes it is probably your white
privilege yes but but that's alright
because I just think it's convenient
when we demographically have more young
people on the planet that we've ever had
before that we have all of these
narratives and discourses of exhaustion
it's just really convenient yeah I just
I'm I guess again look it's hard to have
a political defeat it's hard to
reconstitute oneself when one feels that
one gets kicked in the teeth it is it is
hard to actually mourn it but there's I
again this is probably crazy of me but I
just I don't know I'm not that impressed
I'm not that convinced that human beings
have changed so overwhelmingly that this
these societies were so fantastic tenure
to go it's yes we are in a contested
place yes there's a lot of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] but it's never been cute these
places have never been [ __ ] cute and
I just I don't understand why the
presence of Donald Trump has panicked
everyone you would think [ __ ] Morgoth
has come back you would think like the
Dark Lord is chillin this is this is a
dude who can barely [ __ ] add yo
nothing wrong I'm sorry four people can
add god not to faint praise but I guess
I'm maybe it's cuz I'm a Mets fan for
those of you who don't know anything
about baseball I'm on the side of a team
that never wins I'm I'm used to looking
at people with power and being like
let's [ __ ] em up
what else is there and so I don't buy it
I just don't buy it I was in a country
where there was a civil war and yes
we're really good at tearing ourselves
apart especially when we're the closest
to each other we're especially good of
inventing fissures but I've also seen
that a country like the Dominican
Republic that had a very violent very
bad very just long-lasting acrimonious
civil conflict there's still abilities
for people to create different kinds of
solidarity's the future is unfuckin
written I just think it's so hard for us
to seed the truth about the future and
the truth about the future is that none
of us and as a writer I'm always really
interested in this then none of us know
what the future needs I write a book and
it doesn't make a difference that I get
invited to Denmark and people are like
oh I've read it in 40 years nobody could
know anything about me
the future has the final vote and it is
very difficult for us to allow that
we think that there's something about
the present that gives us special
knowledge about the future but that is a
fantasy you know we're in our present
we've got our challenges we have to do
our fight but the future six months
before Trump got elected you had no idea
Trump was getting elected well if the
bad can surprise us
so can the progressive and yet you've
just edited a special edition of the
person review about global dystopias I
like that [ __ ] yeah why do you like this
Tobias that's crazy well we live in
dystopia so I feel like it's a
vocabulary we're familiar with yeah I
again I just think you dystopias are any
they are discursive instruments par
excellence for understanding our society
and for imagining better places tom
Moylan always said the you know critical
dystopias their function is to map to
warn and to hope and that has been the
use of dystopias forever yeah you show
people a bad society people are like oh
[ __ ] just like my bad Society oh this is
how bad societies function mmm perhaps
it's possible for us to overthrow bad
societies dystopias are great because if
you live in the United States or in
Western world you're told that any
future that doesn't include capitalism
is unimaginable and dystopias and some
of them imagine futures with no
capitalism and even better some of them
imagined futures would know America I
think it's good to imagine future's
window America you know the same way
it's good to imagine futures with no men
and no white people not because we're
encouraging [ __ ] but because as thought
experiments they're very very useful I
just say I I can't help it I look at my
students when I'm in class and I keep
thinking [ __ ] you know what the best
thing what happened to you right now is
if every single person over the age of
32 fell asleep for eight months
it'd be [ __ ] it honestly I don't care
what you say
we wouldn't wake up to a worse Society
maybe I just smoke too much weed but
definitely no so I was gonna ask you
what's your favorite dystopia at the
moment but did we just hear it no that
wouldn't be it that's kind of a utopia
yeah I again I I sort of I reveal my
bald age because I'm a huge fan of
Octavia Butler's dawn I think it's the
greatest dystopia ever and then for the
kind of feed the little ultra-leftist in
me V for Vendetta Allan Ward's comic
book you know you don't always get an
anarchist hero who fights white
supremacist all day long that's great -
I like that so those are - if you
haven't read Octavia Butler's dawn you
really should I think it's one of the
greatest novels of all time what's great
about it I know lots of people here have
probably seen and even read The
Handmaid's Tale and I know you
interviewed Margaret Atwood about it and
that was it the critical dystopia right
that did exactly what you were just
describing does Octavia Butler do the
same similar that assume very much so
very much so
I think it's one of the great books of
all time it imagines what would happen
if what would happen if we found
ourselves all of us victims of an alien
invasion that what they wanted from us
was our genes and how they get them is
that they insert themselves into the
intimate space between people oh and
it's the most disturbing thing I've ever
read
highly it's like erotic vampires really
terrifying
yeah but it's so great on white
supremacy and slavery it's like if you
want a great x-ray of American history
that's go on it's not a bad place to
start I'm I'm curious about this because
I was just rereading your books
preparing for this and I hadn't seen
that
rasca Wow loves like the apocalypse
he loves sort of superheroes destroying
the well I guess saving the world and
villains destroying the world and I
guess in that sense he's a close
relative of yours them
well I when I write my characters I tend
to give them different loves than mine
it's useful that your characters don't
love the same books you do at least for
me I can't keep track of them if they do
you know and and and I like writing
about people who like books I've always
found readers again everyone has their
different bag I have a beloved mentor
the writer scholar critic Samuel R
Delaney and he always makes it clear
he's like ah any time you see my
characters they're always falling in
love what people would really be in up
hands and I I find people with good
books on their shelves very attractive
and so I tend to make my characters even
the bad ones
somehow textually involved textually
involved I'm also just wondering if
that's bringing us back to to where we
started which in the sense that the
deliberate forgetting of stuff is kind
of what you're struggling and it's it
seems this dealing with this Tobias is
also something you find healthy it's
kind of an act against forgetting
looking away that in itself instead of
being afraid just look at in the eye and
and use art for that is that like a
survival mmm survival mechanism a
survival or a sense of creation and Howe
but--look guide whether we're talking
about whiteness maleness straightness
ability we were they're talking about
the poles of privilege at their heart is
the fantasy of innocence denmark's like
America both of these places think
they're [ __ ] innocent they think
everybody else has committed a crime
they're like all these immigrants have
commit a crime
all these [ __ ] black people on the
bus they're criminals all these [ __ ]
Syrians trying to get across our border
they're [ __ ] criminals and the the
nature of innocence
is that to maintain an identity of
innocence requires forgetting and
requires amnesia you have to create
alibis for yourself nations especially
nations that have whiteness at their
heart they cannot exist without the
dream of innocence
we darker bodies are criminalized the
nation is innocent of all crimes and
this for me is not insignificant if you
want to be an artist you have to
understand how a society works because
you are going to be drawing them mapping
them and if you are unaware of how
important innocence is even if you're
just writing about your characters
falling into bed with each other you're
not going to understand the basic social
gravity of your story worlds and I take
this concept of innocence that map it
out over my male characters all day long
they think they're [ __ ] innocent and
they slowly discover for better and for
worse that this innocence is an
ideological project to take out the
ability for people to understand what's
really really happening and that's good
that's sort of uh I think part of what
we call this gnostic project
of removing the veils I think if if
you're not as an artist unless in my
mind if you're not trying desperately to
remove those veils to remove in the
Gnostic terms to remove that you know
that orientalist vision that they have
to kind of take the scales from your
eyes it's it's it's a dead end it's a
dead end
we we we must understand clearly and to
understand clearly as an artist means
that you have to undo a lot of the
negative education they call it negative
hallucination for a reason
negative elucidation is how our
societies teach us to unsee and we have
to do a lot of relearning that unseeing
you know for us to begin to really
understand where we're at and Hoover who
we are I think you just gave a really
good reason to go downstairs after this
and check out the exhibition so
wonderful deserving yeah and I also
think you said something that leads us
to the last paragraph from your books
that I would ask you to read as a final
part of this conversation because this
is a story about jr. suddenly facing
some of the violence underneath his feet
as I read it and I just want to yeah
thank you for this talk and just ask you
to read us a couple of paragraphs about
you nurse experience yeah thank you so
much for being my interlocutor and thank
you all for being so very patient and
very kind so I'll just read this and
then everybody run home and get drunk
or not so all you have to know is my
protagonist dumbass his girlfriend
catches him cheating and so he's crying
because he thinks she's innocent and
he's running around with some
bucketheads and so here we go
and they're at a cave in the dominican
republic that the vice-president of the
country is trying to convince this young
character who has run into the vice
president for reasons that are never
explained that that if he looks into
this cave he will have visions that will
help him clarify where he's at right
would you like to see inside the vice
president asks me I must have said yes
because his bodyguard by de Berto gives
me the flashlight and the two of them
grabbed me by my ankles and lower B into
the hole all my coins fly out of my
pockets bendición s I don't see much
just some odd colors on the eroded walls
and the vice president's calling down
isn't it beautiful this is the perfect
place for insight for a person to become
something better
the vice president probably saw his
future self hanging in this darkness
bulldozing the poor out of their
shanties and body bottle to buying a
concrete house for his mother showing
her how to work the air conditioner but
for me all I can manage is a memory of
the first time me and Magda talked back
at Rutgers we were rating for an e bus
together on George Street and she was
wearing purple all sorts of purple and
that's when I know it's over as soon as
you start thinking about the beginning
it is the end thank you thank you
[Applause]
you